one of the strangest and saddest
phenomena of psychological life
that there are parents too many parents
who end up while sometimes only half
realizing it bullying their own children
why do parents bully their children in
short in order to try to feel better
about themselves because they suffer
intensely in the very same area that
they are choosing to bully their child
in someone made them feel awful and they
surmise by Twisted logic that they will
feel better through the process of
making their own child feel very bad
indeed they aren't doing it personally
the child is just collateral damage to a
misguided project of healing and an
attenuation of symptoms it doesn't make
any sense of course but it may actually
work for the parent for a Time
let's imagine a parent who Harbors a
terrible fear of being stupid somewhere
in their own past they were belittled
and made to feel hugely inadequate now a
child comes along their own child full
of the normal hesitations and weaknesses
of early infancy
Without Really realizing what they're up
to the parent grows inflamed and
incensed by this child's apparent
stupidity and starts to mock an attack
in another person what they fear and
hate in themselves it makes them feel a
bit better the child becomes a
repository of all that they fail to
tolerate in themselves they the child
are the dumb one so they the parent
don't have to be they the child are the
stupid and ugly one so they the parent
don't have to be and therefore the
parent is liberated to live more easily
within itself the bad is contained and
localized it can't be in them if it's
all in little him or her it can take
bullied children a very long time to
realize that they have even been bullied
they don't after all grow up thinking
that someone else has actually made them
feel stupid or made them feel ugly or
made them feel soiled let alone their
own parent whom they depend on and
admire and long to be loved by the they
simply think that they are stupid ugly
and soiled there is no call for an
explanation or a Cause
yet if we are those now grown up bullied
children we don't need to wander too
much more about what might have happened
to us we simply need to take stock of
how we feel about ourselves and guess
that the terrible judgments and
Sensations that we have about ourselves
did not arise spontaneously the feelings
we Harbor of ourselves are legacies of
real occurrences in the world someone
who isn't necessarily owning up to it
made us feel a certain way and that is
why now we are in such pain
typically those who've been bullied
Don't Look Backwards their illnesses
Point them relentlessly to the present
and the future the bullied anticipate
terrible things happening to them that
Echo events that once happened to them
but that they don't remember in any way
they are causeless paranoia's
self-haters and warriors catastrophe is
never far away a person feels they're
ugly because two decades ago a mother
made them feel as such a person feels
they've done something very wrong
because even further back someone did
something very wrong to them the fear
contains the imprint of unconscious
history
we overcome our bullying when we learn
to discriminate between what actually
belongs to us and what was placed in US
between who we are and what we've been
told we are between how our caregivers
like to present themselves and what
they've actually done are triggers and
apprehensions lie along the fault lines
of our early traumas so they can guide
us back to what we suffered through when
we are ready to explore
we're on our way to overcoming bullying
when we can say at last I'm not ugly I
was made to feel unacceptable I haven't
done anything wrong something wrong was
done to me and in general I am not awful
something awful happened to me